All transcription factors have an optimal DNA sequence that
they can bind strongly to. Let's use the example that
we just looked at. If we use this sequence,
what this means is that, a transcription factor, if it's
present, will bind this sequence, and strongly. But because
this is chemistry, if we change 1 or 2 of
the letters here, then we're going to change the interaction that
the protein can have with sequence After all the protein
can still recognize other letters in the sequence. So we expect it to
still be able to bind, but maybe not as strongly. So if we
change the sequence to something like this what will happen is the protein
can still bind, but less strongly
and less frequently thus reducing overall transcription.